on the islands of Indonesia a geological
Beast is Awakening
Krakatoa is about to blow
again
how would you know this day was coming
how could this eruption make you deaf
and why could it be a good thing for our
planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Krakatoa erupted today
it's August
1883 in Indonesia and one of the most
catastrophic natural events in recorded
history has just occurred
Krakatoa a volcano on the island of
Rakata has erupted violently sending
enormous amounts of gas and Ash High
into the air
the explosion was so energetic that its
sound traveled a distance about the
width of the United States
wow
even though this volcanic island was
uninhabited at the time the devastating
aftermath of the eruption led to a death
toll as high as 36 000 people
and that's not all it also caused a
little climate change
so if Krakatoa were to erupt today would
it be game over for Humanity
if this volcano violently erupted life
on Earth could turn into a hellscape
well I have news for you thanks to our
consuming habits we already faced that
threat every day look big box stores may
have the best deals but these are the
biggest ocean polluters around those low
prices come at the cost of high CO2 and
methane emissions so find companies that
score well under environmental social
and governance testing it's simple how
does the company impact the environment
how does the company improve its social
impact and how does their board Drive
positive change
you can make sure your voice is heard
and that companies and representatives
know that more environmentally friendly
approaches to business are important for
all of us check out the ship at zero
campaign research and start using your
buying power to protect our planet
consume ethically now because if this
Monster blows the only thing you can buy
is timed
before jumping right into the heart of
this volcanic disaster scenario there's
one important detail you need to know
following its eruption in 1883 a large
part of the Krakatoa volcano collapsed
into the sea it kept erupting underwater
and that allowed the volcano to climb
back out of the ocean but when Krakatoa
erupted back then it was twice as tall
as it is today
for today's Krakatoa to be extremely
dangerous it would have to return to its
original size
so let's imagine a scenario where the
1883 eruption never happened and this
volcano would be a ticking Time Bomb
ready to blow
if you lived in Indonesia's Capital
Jakarta you'd be among the first to
notice that something was wrong
for months you'd be hearing strange dull
booming noises followed by your doors
and windows violently rattling
these booms would be the result of
eruptions below the surface of the
Indian Ocean
in the days after these booms Krakatoa
would start to blow up
small amounts of Ash would rain down as
far away as Southern India or Thailand
closer to ricotta Island where you could
see Krakatoa large volumes of steam and
smoke would be rising from its peak into
the atmosphere
over the next few weeks massive amounts
of volcanic glass and molten rock would
be ejected
this rock material would blanket parts
of the ocean's surface around the island
and that would just be the beginning of
the disruptions the fishing industry
shipping lanes and to all life forms in
the coastal ecosystem
eventually that Tower of steam smoke and
Rocky material would get huge
the volcano would violently spew gas and
Ash as high up as 25 kilometers into the
air
yeah impressive but this portal to the
underworld is saving its Big Show for
tomorrow
the next day this Beast would explode
with so much energy that its sound waves
would Circle The Globe four times and
while not everyone on Earth would hear
the noise you could catch it in
Australia
yeah even 160 kilometers away the
explosion would sound louder than a jet
engine
hopefully you won't be any closer than
that because if you were too close the
bang would instantly rupture your
eardrums
following the explosion the surrounding
regions would be plunged Into Darkness
that's because all the volcanic ash that
Krakatoa spit out into the sky would be
blocking the sunlight for the next three
days
but the worst would be yet to come
this massive explosion would cause the
volcano to collapse large parts of
Krakatoa would fall into the sea
triggering a series of devastating
tsunamis
millions of people in the surrounding
area of Indonesia would be at risk of
death
if you lived in Jakarta you'd want to
find some very high ground because a
wave of over 37 meters tall would drench
the capital
and people in coastal areas as far away
as Hawaii and South America would be on
tsunami watch as well
now if flights weren't already canceled
planes would start falling out of the
sky
visibility would be reduced to a minimum
but the big threat would come from the
volcanic ash clouds they can damage
flight controls and cause engines to
fail
the eruption would produce an enormous
amount of dust and debris so much that
if it all fell onto one place like New
York City only the antenna of the Empire
State Building would be peeking out
Indonesia and other parts of Southeast
Asia and Australia would be devastated
by all the ash falling onto their
farmland
many crops and livestock would struggle
to survive in this ash contaminated
environment
now believe it or not something positive
might come from all this destruction
it could be a cure for climate change
well at least for a little while
when Krakatoa exploded in 1883 it
lowered the average global temperature
for several years
plus all that fine dust in the air would
create some stunning views
for the next year sunsets and sunrises
would take on a spectacular red and
orange glow
and the Sun and the Moon would appear
greener than you've ever seen them
before
[Music]
speaking of changing the sun's color
what would it be like if the sun turned
from yellow to Blue
well you know what I always say
that's a story
for another
what if